I've been a little critical of the
bullet uh lately and I I do it I really
do do it as a way of trying to help the
bullet I've never met her I think I'm
being helpful to her but the crowd isn't
like the bullet is the people who don't
know which is the problem that you're
talking about she is quite possibly the
the greatest Talent I've ever seen in
unarmed combat she is fantastic uh her
skills seem to be equal on the ground as
to standing up she can finish fights
anywhere she can deal with adversity she
can push the pace she's actually
weaponized Pace I'm much like uh Dan
Gable did way back in 1972 she is flat
impressive she's also a co-main event
you can't make a dollar with the girl
you can't put her against any opponent
she's fighting this weekend I don't know
who her opponent is and I'm not
attempting to be funny I simply you
could give me multiple choice I wouldn't
know but that's her fault you know I
watched Ron Ariel yesterday and she's
sitting there you know they call it
crisscross applesauce and she's telling
some stories she's trying to tell like
we're five-year-olds and like she's the
kindergarten teacher it's like girl
strip your clothes off you got tattoos
supposedly you speak seven languages man
I'm not even sure you've mastered
English which is speaking to us now
you're not overly uh impressive and
you're a co-main event above everything
else what are you a goddamn which you
have to say or how many World
Championships you have you can't even
close out the night you got a guy named
surreal gone who's one and one in his
last two and he's walking out after you
there's a Miss there and I don't say
that to put her down she's wildly
successful but why she keeps trying to
pretend that she's a sweet Sally
Homemaker when she's not what should she
be what would you do with her I think in
real life she's a heel I don't know her
I haven't met her personally but I think
she's a heel I've seen her interviews
I've seen her come uh to the aid and to
the defense of some very unsavory
characters and I just thought to myself
you seem like a bad girl when Jon Jones
went down for every steroid in the world
and street drugs and cocaine and he ran
his car and she was the first to come
and defend which was very sweet she has
the courage to come out of the fit it
was very sweet but it also isn't what
your kindergarten teacher that she'd
like you to think that she is with you
and I look at her and go you're a heel
just be yourself is there another reason
why she might have of course
to come in
[Music]
there's breakups I mean all of these
things can be Googled you just have to
connect with us and if you did connect
the Dos you could make some money and
sell some tickets but they don't have
the courage to connect the dots they
gotta just leave it lingering we're
trying to get somebody to watch a girl
into the comment event you could make
her money right now right you just said
what you were feeling right now you
think that there might be fill out an
arena to fight Holly Holm if they would
just tell the story and what's the story
Holly over he got Valentina here and you
got John over here no I'm not connected
but these are your three what with the
story possible maybe Jon Jones was like
in an intimate relationship perhaps with
Hollywood let's make it up yeah the the
bullet shivchenko
came in and stole John Jones from that
if that happens Hollywood fight the
bullet
and Hollywood want to get revenge on the
girl that's stole her man a bullet who
lives over here got assigned to the
March 4th card which Jon Jones's
headline and they're all the same hotel
right now
that
I don't know I don't know that's an
incredible tale that you're that'd be
crazy if that happened yeah and um but
imagine that that happened and they came
out and they told the world instead of
hiding
Heidi imagine
tourist that you could possibly have
one is the world champion who's won more
World Championship the the other's not
do you understand that we have a world
title fight that is not the main event
on a card we have a non-world title
fight that's headlining the card that's
a problem for them yeah for them that's
a problem that could be changed but it
would take courage to tell a story does
it have anything to do with their
genitals I don't know hmm I mean I don't
know I think you're talking about the
the men traditionally do better I mean
we saw UFC was it 200 Miesha Tate Amanda
Nunes so we have seen the woman uh go
later before but it is it is a hard fact
of a policy that a championship match
closes out the night I'm saying that
there needs to be a story I agree with
you I I don't even know what the story
is
understand that she is such a bad draw
that they are breaking but there is a oh
because the headline the belt has the
headline well it is headlining I think
Jon Jones and Sarah gone are gone are
fighting for the belt but neither of one
of them is Champion that's the
difference ah you're saying the champion
always has to headline and that is a
policy that they have never broken and
she does such a bad job that they have
to break their own policy because they
can't walk around you want her to say I
stole your man I want her to come I want
to knock you out after yeah I don't want
her to come out and do this pretending
she speaks seven languages I don't want
her to come out and pretend that she's
trained in the military I don't want her
to come out and act she's got a sister
in the business her mother was a world
champion she grew up in a very rough
household and she is an incredible uh
story and an incredible product of a
very difficult upbringing she is not a
kindergarten teacher she is not a nice
girl she has tattoos on her body she
gets in a cage and she tries to hurt
other people that she was trained and
designed to do there's nothing wrong
with telling that story but when she
tries to fool the audience yeah you have
a comment would you consider being like
a consultant for a league because it
feels like you can sell a storyline in
the way like um Eric Bischoff who did
WWE sure I remember Eric and you yes
yeah yeah I feel like you could do a
very similar thing I don't I'm sure
you're making a lot of money Now podcast
is 12 times bigger than ours but
uh I think you can make a lot of money
doing that I appreciate that and I just
think there's a story and I have to say
this Andrew because it's important to me
because I didn't come here to give the
bullet a hard time or even outer Dirty
Laundry like I think that she's a really
interesting gal I had a dream and I
worked really hard
and I fell short I didn't get to as good
as she was or as talented or as many
wins and as many Gold Belts and I had
doing laundry with Holly Holm clean it
doesn't happen in the past like that
would be a really incredible reason for
them to fight it really would I mean you
have two people that just can't draw
flies and and I don't say it to pick on
her I say it because there's a
difference if you're going to come out
you're going to do the interview anyway
yeah one you can sit crisscross
applesauce and speak to the audience
or the other one you can come on to
Ariel's show talk about the world
championship the next girl you're gonna
beat up and by the way I'm gonna stop by
this guy's room in the meantime damn his
legs his knees might be weak by the time
he walks in the main event because of me
the night before there's a way to tell a
story
come out and tell the story so what
makes a better fight two heels or a heel
in the face well there's there's nothing
more monetizable than a cool heel now a
cool heel is hard to come by
Stone Cold yeah the rock uh we're cool
heels man if you throw me in there that
was very sweet of you but Conor would go
into that category too Connor didn't
come out to get she already came out to
get booed but then he kind of looked
cool doing it and he had the bow tie and
you had the accent and you know he got a
good little build on him and all of a
sudden he wins World Championships he's
headlined Madison Square Garden I mean
some of that stuff just happened yeah
the other part you can manufacture I I
just suggest if you have a store to tell
your story that would be my only advice
if you have a story tell your story if
you try to lie to the audience like
chefchenko you're going to end up a
co-man event if you're happy in your
career talk about the time that you
one fights in a comet event spot do it
your way so it's better to have two
heels but if they're cool heels that's
even better I think it's just better to
tell the story the way that it happened
if you got a reason to fight this person
tell what it is if you have no you don't
don't even know who this person is and
Dana White drew the name out of a hat
you got a phone call one day tell that
if that's really is the story then go
out and tell her because that's also
being a heel yeah I don't know who this
girl is sure Dana White put pick the
name out of a hat I have no [__] clue
who she is but I'm gonna get paid money
to go there and beat her ass yeah and
it's low level that's condescending it's
like the new boyfriend has to act like
he doesn't know the old boyfriend's name
you know it's not James Jack call him
John I mean there's some stuff that's
bigger than all of us I would just store
for you if you're telling a story and
you have a really good one to tell